Young man,
why aren't you eating that fish?
Fish you love to fish.
That's why you took it out of the water
and killed it and boiled it.
He says,
don't tell me you love the fish.
You love yourself and because the fish
tastes good to you,
therefore you took it out of the water
and killed it and boiled it so much of
what his love is.
Fish off,
right and so young.
Couple of falls in love,
young man,
young woman falling in love.
What does that mean?
That means that he saw in this woman
someone who we felt could provide him
with knowledge,
just physical and emotional needs,
and she thought this meant somebody.
She feels that she can write that was
love,
but each one is looking out for their
own needs.
It's not love for the other.
The other person becomes a vehicle for,
for my gratification,
too much of what is called love is fish.
Love external love is man on what I'm
going to get,
but what I'm going to get.
We had an ethicist rabbi Tessler who
said,
people make a serious mistake in
thinking that you give to those who
love.
The answer is.
The real answer is you love those too,
and this point is if I give something to
you,
I've invested myself in you and seeing
this self love is a given.
Everybody loves themselves.
Now that part of me has become a new
right.
There's part of me knew that I love true
love is a love of giving and receiving.